Este soy yo, me llamo Ben Saunders.
Soy especialista en arrastrar cosas pesadas
en lugares fríos.
El 11 de mayo del año pasado,
me encontraba solo en el Polo Norte geográfico.
Era el único ser humano en un área
una vez y media más grande que América;
14.245 kilómetros cuadrados.
Más de 2.000 personas han escalado el Everest.
12 personas han pisado la Luna.
Incluyéndome a mí, sólo cuatro personas
han esquiado en solitario al Polo Norte.
Pienso que la razón de que...
(Aplausos)
-- gracias-- Pienso que la razón es que es--- es---
bueno es, como dijo Chris, es de flipaos.
Es un viaje que llega al límite mismo
de la capacidad humana.
Esquié el equivalente a 31 maratones
ininterumpidos. 1.288 kilómetros en 10 semanas.
Y arrastraba toda la comida,
los suministros, el equipo, saco de dormir,
una muda de ropa interior -- todo lo que necesitaba para casi tres meses.
(Risas)
Lo que vamos a intentar hacer hoy, en los 16 minutos que me quedan,
es responder a tres preguntas. La primera es ¿por qué?
La segunda es,
¿cómo se va al baño a menos 40 grados?
"Ben, he leido en algún sitio que a menos 40 grados,
la piel expuesta se congela en menos de un minuto, asi que ¿cómo se responde a la llamada de la naturaleza?
No quiero contestar a esto ahora. Volveré sobre ello al final.
La tercera: ¿Cómo superar eso? ¿Qué es lo que viene después?
Todo comenzó en 2001.
Mi primera expedición fue con Pen Hadow -- un tipo con muchísima experiencia.
Era como mi práctica en el polo.
Estabamos intentando esquiar desde este grupo de islas aquí arriba,
Sévernaya Zemlyá, al Polo Norte.
Y lo que a mi me fascina del Polo Norte,
el Polo Norte geográfico, es que está justo en el mismísimo centro del océano.
Los mapas no llegan a ser más precisos que esto,
y para alcanzarlo tienes que esquiar literalmente
sobre la corteza helada,
la superficie de hielo flotante en el Océano Ártico.
Habia hablado con todos los expertos.
Había leido un montón de libros, estudié mapas y gráficos.
Pero me dí cuenta en la mañana del día uno
que no tenía ni idea
de en qué me había metido exactamente.
Tenía 23 años. Nadie de mi edad
había intentado nada parecido,
y enseguida, todo lo que podía ir mal,
empezó a ir mal.
Fuimos atacados por un oso polar en el día dos.
Se me había congelado el dedo gordo del pie izquierdo.
La comida comenzó a escasear. Los dos teníamos bastante hambre, perdíamos mucho peso.
Se dieron circunstancias climáticas muy inusuales, condiciones de hielo muy difíciles.
Teníamos,
sin duda alguna, sistemas de comunicación de tecnología rudimentaria.
No pudímos permitirnos un teléfono por satélite, así que teníamos una radio de onda corta.
Se pueden ver dos bastones de ski saliendo del tejado de la tienda.
Hay un cable que cuelga por ambos lados.
Es nuestra antena de onda corta.
Tuvimos menos de dos horas de comunicación
con el mundo exterior en dos meses.
Al final, se nos agotó el tiempo.
Habíamos esquiado 644 kilómetros. Nos quedaban un poco más de 322 km
para llegar al Polo, y se nos había agotado el tiempo.
Se nos había echado encima el verano, y el hielo había comenzado a derretirse,
hablamos con los pilotos de helicóptero rusos por radio,
y dijeron, " Vean chicos, se les ha agotado el tiempo.
Tenemos que ir a recogerlos."
Sentí que había fracasado, con todo mi empeño.
Era un fracasado.
El único objetivo, el único sueño que tenía,
que tenía desde que puedo recordar -- y ni siquiera había estado cerca.
Esquiando a lo largo de aquel viaje, había dos
videoclips imaginarios que se repetían en mi cerebro una y otra vez,
para mantener mi nivel de motivación, cuando las cosas se ponían feas.
La primera era al llegar al Polo mismo.
Podía ver de una manera muy real, supongo que
estaba siendo grabado a través de la puerta del helicóptero, había música rock de fondo,
tenía un bastón de esquí con la bandera inglesa, volando al viento.
Podía verme a mi mismo clavando aquella bandera en el polo, ya sabes,
ah, un momento glorioso-- la música alcanzando el crescendo.
El segundo videoclip
que me imaginaba era a la llegada al aeropuerto de Heathrow,
podía ver de nuevo de una manera muy real,
los flashes de las cámaras disparándose
los paparazzi, los cazadores de autógrafos,
los agentes literarios con contratos.
Y por supuesto, ninguna de estas dos cosas sucedieron.
No alcanzamos el Polo y no teníamos dinero
para pagar a nadie para que hiciera relaciones públicas, asi que nadie oyó
nada sobre esta expedición.
Y llegué a Heathrow. Estaba mi madre, mi hermano
mi abuelo estaba allí-- tenía una pequeña bandera británica
Risas
-- y eso fué todo. Volví a casa con mi madre.
Estaba exhausto físicamente,
y mentalmente hecho un verdadero desastre, me consideraba un fracasado.
Tenía una deuda personal enorme a consecuencia de esta expedición
y tirado en el sofá de mi madre,
día sí día también, viendo la programación diurna en la tele.
Mi hermano me mandó un mensaje de texto, un SMS, era ---
era una cita de los Simpsons. Decía,
"Lo intentaste con todas tus fuerzas y fracasaste miserablemente.
La lección es: ni lo intentes."
(Risas)
Avanzando rápido tres años. Eventualmente sí me levanté del sofá
y empecé a planear otra expedición. Esta vez
quería hacer una travesía, en solitario esta vez,
desde Rusia, arriba del mapa,
hasta el Polo Norte, allí en el meollo,
y después seguir hasta Canadá.
Nadie había atravesado el Océano Ártico en solitario.
Dos noruegos lo habían logrado como equipo en el 2000. Pero nadie lo había hecho solo.
El muy famoso, muy destacado montañero italiano
Reinhold Messner, lo intentó en 1995,
pero fue rescatado una semana después.
Describió esta expedición como 10 veces
más peligrosa que subir al Everest.
Por alguna razón esto era lo que me tiraba,
pero sabía que para tener alguna posibilidad de llegar a casa de una sola pieza,
incluso llegar a Canadá,
tenía que afrontar las cosas de una manera radical.
Esto implicaba perfeccionar todo
desde el cepillo de dientes aserrado de menos de 2 gramos,
hasta trabajar con uno de los líderes a nivel mundial en nutrición
para desarrollar desde cero una
estrategia nutricional nueva y revolucionaria:
6,000 calorias diarias.
Y la expedición empezó en febrero del año pasado.
Un gran equipo de apoyo. Teníamos un equipo de grabación.
un par de personas de logística con nosotros,
mi novia, un fotógrafo.
Al principio fué bastante razonable. Volamos con British Airways a Moscú.
El siguiente trecho en Siberia a Krasnoyarsk,
con una compañía aérea rusa llamada KrasAir,
escrito K-R-A-S.
El siguiente tramo, contratamos un avión ruso bastante anciano
que nos llevó hasta un pueblo llamado Khatanga.
que era como el último bastión de la civilización.
Nuestro camarógrafo, quien resultó ser un puro nervio a la hora de volar, en el mejor de los casos,
preguntó al piloto, antes de subirnos al avión, cuanto tiempo iba a durar el vuelo,
y el piloto --piloto ruso-
respondió, seis horas --si sobrevivimos.
(Risas)
Llegamos a Khatanga.
Creo que el chiste es que Khatanga no es el fin del mundo,
pero se vé desde allí.
(Risas)
Se suponía que nos quedabamos una noche. Estuvimos 10 días atrapados.
Había una especie de discusión, alimentada por el vodka, sobre el salario entre
los pilotos del helicóptero y los dueños del helicóptero,
estabamos atascados. No podíamos movernos.
Finalmente, en la mañana del día 11, nos dieron el permiso para salir,
cargamos los helicópteros -- dos helicópteros volando en tandem--
me soltaron al borde de la capa de hielo.
Tuvimos unos, alrededor de 45 minutos, de grabación frenética,
y sesión fotográfica, mientras el helicóptero aún estaba allí.
Hice una entrevista teléfonica via satélite,
entonces todo el mundo volvió a subir al helicóptero,
y wham, la puerta se cerró y estaba solo.
No se si las palabras llegaran a hacer justicia a aquél momento.
Lo único en lo que podía pensar era correr hacia la puerta,
golpearla y decir, "Mirar chicos,
casi no lo he pensado bien."
(Risas)
Para empeorar las cosas, podeis ver el punto blanco
en la parte superior derecha de la panatalla, la luna llena.
Por haber sido retenidos en Rusia, claro,
la luna llena trae las mareas más altas y más bajas;
cuando estás encima de la capa helada del mar,
las mareas altas y bajas generalmente significan
que van a suceder cosas interesante -- el hielo va a comenzar a moverse.
Yo estaba, podeis verlo ahí, arrastrando dos trineos.
Un gran total de comida y combustible para 95 días,
180 kilos --casi exactamente 400 libras.
Cuando el hielo era llano o casi.
podía arrastrar los dos trineos a la vez.
Cuando el hielo no era llano, no tenía ni la más remota posibilidad.
Tenía que arrastrar uno, dejarlo, volver a por el otro.
Gatear literalmente por lo que se llaman crestas --
hielo que ha sido machacado por la presión de las corrientes del océano,
el viento y las mareas.
La Nasa describe las condiciones del hielo del año pasado como las peores desde el inicio del registro.
Y siempre está a la deriva. La corteza helada siempre está a la deriva.
Esquié contra el viento durante 9 de
las 10 semanas en las que estuve solo el año pasado.
y la mayor parte del tiempo la corriente me llevaba para atrás.
Mi record era menos 4.02 kilómetros.
Me levantaba por la mañana, desmontaba la tienda y esquiaba hacia el norte durante siete horas y media,
levantaba la tienda, y estaba 4.02 kilómetros más atrás
que donde empecé.
No podía vencer a la velocidad de deriva del hielo.
(Video) Asi que es el día 22.
Estoy acostado en la tienda, preparándome para salir.
El tiempo es horroroso --
me ha llevado la corriente unos 8 kilómetros hacia atrás
en la ultima -- última noche.
Más tarde en la expedición, el problema ya no era el hielo.
Era la falta de hielo -- mar abierto.
Sabía que estaba ocurriendo. Sabía que el Ártico se estaba calentando.
Sabía que había mar abierto. Y tenía un arma secreta en la manga.
Un poco de bio-imitación.
Los osos polares se mueven por el Océano Ártico en linea recta.
Si llegan al agua, se meten y nadan hasta la otra orilla.
Desarrollamos un traje seco -- trabajé con un equipo en Noruega --
basado en un especie de traje de supervivencia --
que supongo, llevan los pilotos de helicópteros --
en el que me podía meter. Me lo ponía sobre las botas y los guantes,
y se cerraba alrededor de la cara de manera que quedaba bastante sellado.
Eso significaba que podía esquiar
sobre hielo muy fino,
y si me caía dentro, no era el fin del mundo.
También significaba, llegado lo peor,
que podía meterme en el agua y nadar hasta la otra orilla
arrastrando el trineo conmigo.
Una tecnología bastante radical,
un enfoque radical -- pero funcionó perfectamente.
Otra cosa emocionante que hicimos el año pasado
fue con la tecnología de comunicaciones.
En 1912, en la Expedición de resistencia de Shackelton --
había -- un miembro del equipo, un tipo llamado Thomas Orde-Lees.
Dijo: "Los exploradores del 2012,
si queda algo por explorar,
sin duda llevarán en sus bolsillos teléfonos inalámbrico
equipados con telescopios inalámbricos."
Pues, Orde-Lees se equivocó en alrededor de 8 años. Este es mi teléfono inalámbrico de bolsillo.
El teléfono por satélite Iridium.
El telescopio inalámbrico era una cámara digital guardada en mi bolsillo.
Y cada uno de los 72 días que estuve solo en el hielo,
estaba blogeando en directo desde mi tienda de campaña,
enviando un pequeño diario,
enviando información sobre la distancia que había cubierto --
las condiciones del hielo, la temperatura --
y una foto diaria.
Recordad 2001
teníamos menos de dos horas de comunicación por radio con el mundo exterior.
El año pasado, blogeando en directo desde la expedición
que ha sido descrita como 10 veces más peligrosa que escalar el Everest.
No fué todo alta tecnología. Aqui estoy navegando
en lo que se llama "apagón blanco".
Es cuando hay mucha niebla, nubes bajas, y el viento comienza a levantar la nieve.
No se puede ver demasiado. Apenas se ve que hay un lazo amarillo
atado a uno de mis bastones de esqui.
Navegaba guiado por la dirección del viento.
Era una especie de combinación extraña de tecnología puntera y recursos rudimentarios.
Acancé el Polo el 11 de mayo.
Me llevó 68 días alcanzarlo desde Rusia.
y no había nada allí.
(Risas)
Ni siquiera hay un poste en el Polo. No hay nada,
sinceramente porque es océano helado. Vá a la deriva.
Clavas allí una bandera, la dejas, y pronto se alejará a la deriva, normalmente hacia Canadá o Groenlandia.
Yo lo sabía, pero aún así esperaba algo.
Extraña mezcla de sentimientos: hacía un tiempo bastante cálido en esta época,
mucha mar abierto alrededor, y
claro, encantado de haber llegado impulsado por mi propio gas,
pero empecé a darme cuenta
que las posibilidades de lograr alcanzar la costa de Canadá,
que aún distaba 644 kilómetros,
eran mínimas en el mejor de los casos.
La única prueba de que estuve allí que tengo
es una foto borrosa de mi GPS, el artilugio de navegación por satélite.
Se alcanza ver --
hay un nueve y una cadena de ceros aqui.
Noventa grados norte -- eso es justo en el mismo Polo Norte.
Tomé una foto. Me senté en el trineo. Grabé una especie de videopieza para el diario.
Saqué unas cuantas fotos. Cogí mi teléfono por satélite.
Calenté la bateria bajo el brazo.
Marqué trés números. Llamé a mi madre.
Llamé a mi novia. Llamé al ejecutivo jefe de mi sponsor.
Recibí tres mensajes de voz.
(Risas)
(Video) Noventa
Es una sensación especial.
El planeta entero
está rotando
bajo mis pies.
El -- el mundo entero debajo de mi.
Finalmente conseguí contactar con mi madre. Estaba en la cola del supermercado.
Empezó a llorar. Me pidió que la llamara de nuevo en un momento.
(Risas)
Seguí esquiando durante una semana pasado el Polo.
Quería llegar lo más cerca que podía de Canadá
antes de que las condiciones se volvieran demasiado peligrosas.
Este fué el último día que estuve en el hielo.
Cuando hablé con -- el equipo de producción del proyecto,
dijeron, "Mira, Ben, las situación se está volviendo demasiado peligrosa.
Hay zonas inmensas de mar abierto justo al sur de tu posición.
Nos gustaría recogerte.
Ben, podrías buscar una pista?"
Esto son las vistas fuera de mi tienda de campaña
cuando tuve esta significativa llamada.
Nunca antes había intentado construir una pista. Tony el productor de la expedición me dijo,
"Mira Ben, tienes que encontrar 500 metros de
hielo llano, seguro y con suficiente espesor."
El único cacho de hielo que pude encontrar --
me llevó 36 horas esquiando intentar encontrar la pista--
medía exactamente 473 metros. Podía medirlo con mis esquis.
No se lo dije a Tony. No se lo dije a los pilotos.
Pensé tendrá que servir.
(Video) Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Casi sirvió. Un aterrizaje bastante dramático --
el avión en realidad sobrevoló unas cuatro veces,
y estaba un poco preocupado de que no iba a aterrizar.
El piloto, sabía, se llamaba Troy. Esperaba a alguien llamado Troy
hacía esto para ganarse la vida, un tipo bastante duro.
Estaba llorando a moco tendido para cuando aterrizó el avión, un momento bastante emotivo.
Así que pensé. Tengo que recomponerme para Troy.
Se supone que soy un explorador, un tipo duro.
El avión llego a donde estaba yo.
La puerta se abrió. Un tipo salió. Era como así de alto. Dijo, "Hola, mi llamo Troy."
(Risas)
El copiloto era una señora llamada Monica.
Estaba allí sentada en un especie de jersey tejido a mano.
Eran la gente menos macho que había conocido, pero me alegraron el día.
Troy -- Troy estaba fumandose un cigarillo en el hielo,
sacamos unas cuantas fotos. El --
subió la escalerilla. Dijo, "Sube -- sube atrás."
Tiró su cigarillo mientras se subió delante,
yo me metí detrás.
(Risas)
Recorrimos la pista unas cuantas veces,
para allanarlo un poquito, y dijo, "Bien, voy a --
voy a intentarlo." Y --
ahora ya sé que esto es una práctica habitual, pero en aquel momento me preocupó.
Puso su mano en la palanca.
Como se vé el control del motor está en el techo de la cabina.
Es esa pequeña barra ahí. Puso su mano en la palanca.
Monica suavemente puso su mano como encima de la suya.
Pensé, "Dios allá vamos. Vamos, vamos -- es todo o nada."
Lo lanzó hacia delante. Botando por la pista. Despegamos.
Uno de los esquís rompió el borde de una cresta de hielo al final de la pista,
desestabilando la nave. Podía ver en la cabina a Troy batallando con los mandos,
soltó una mano y llegó hacia atrás
moviendo un interruptor en el techo de la cabina,
era la señal de "abróchense los cinturones" que podeis ver en la pared.
(Risas)
Y sólo desde el aire pude ver la imagen en grande.
Claro, cuando estas en el hielo, sólo puedes ver un obstáculo a la vez,
si es una cresta o si es un parche de agua.
Esto es probablemente la razón por la que no me la cargué por el tamaño de la pista.
Quiero decir, realmente se estaba comenzando a deshacer.
¿Porqué? No soy un explorador en el sentido traditional.
No esquio por lugares dibujados en los mapas
todo el mundo sabe donde está el Polo Norte.
En el Polo Sur hay una gran base científica. Hay una pista de despegue.
Hay un café y una tienda para turistas
Para mí, esto se trataba de explorar los límites humanos,
explorar los límites fisiológicos, psicológicos
y tecnológicos. Eso son las cosas que me entusiasman.
Y también se trata de potencial, a nivel personal.
Esto, para mi, es la oportunidad de explorar los límites --
realmente tensar los límites de mi propio potencial, ver cuanto se estiran.
Y en una escala más ámplia, me sorprende como la gente va por la vida
sólo rascando la superficie de su potiencial,
haciendo sólo tres o cuatro o cinco por ciento
de lo que realmente son capaces. Asi
que a una escala mayor, espero que este viaje
haya sido una oportunidad para inspirar a otras personas
para que piensen sobre lo que ellos quieren hacer
con su potencial, y que quieren hacer con el poquito tiempo que
cada uno tiene en este planeta.
Eso es lo más cerca que llego a resumir todo esto.
La siguiente pregunta es, ¿cómo haces tus necesidades a menos 40 grados?
La respuesta, por supuesto, es un secreto profesional --
y la última cuestión,
¿qué hacer ahora? Lo más rápido posible,
si tengo un minuto al final entraré en más detalle.
Qué sigue:
Antártida
Es el continente más frío, más alto,
ventoso, y seco de la Tierra.
Al final de 1911, principios de 1912,
hubo una carrera para ser el primero en llegar
al Polo Sur: el corazón del continente antártico.
Si se incluyen las barreras de hielo de la costa, se ve la Barrera de hielo de Ross --
es la grande de aquí abajo -- la barrera de hielo de Ross es del tamaño de Francia.
La Antártida, si se incluyen las barreras de hielo,
es dos veces el tamaño de Australia -- es un sitio muy grande.
Hubo una carrera por llegar al Polo entre Amundsen,
el noruego -- Amundsen tenía trineos tirados por perros y huskies --
y Scott, el británico, el capitán Scott.
Scott tenía una especie de ponis y algunos tractores
y algunos perros, todo le falló,
y Scott y su equipo de cuatro personas acabaron a pie.
Llegaron al Polo al final de enero de 1912
para encontrar allí una bandera noruega.
Había una tienda de campaña, una carta al rey de noruega.
Se dieron la vuelta y regresaron a la costa,
los cinco murieron en el viaje de regreso.
Desde entonces, nadie ha esquiado --
eso fué hace 93 años -- desde entonces nadie ha esquiado
desde la costa de la Antártida al Polo y vuelta.
En cada expedición al Polo Sur de la que hayais podido oir
se ha volado desde el Polo o se han utilizado vehículos
o perros o parapentes para hacer algún tipo de cruce --
nadie ha realizado el viaje de vuelta. Asi que ese es el plan-
Vamos a ser dos
Y eso es todo.
Una última cosa antes de que vuelva sobre lo de la función fisiológica, es--
es, tengo -- quería haberlo escaneado pero se me olvidó --
tengo -- unas notas del colegio. Tenía 13 años,
las he colgado sobre mi mesa en casa. Dice,
"Ben carece del suficiente ímpetu
para lograr algo que valga la pena."
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Creo que si he aprendido algo, es esto: nadie
tiene autoridad sobre tu potencial.
Tú eres la única persona que decide cuán lejos quieres llegar y de lo que eres capaz.
Señoras y caballeros, esa es mi historia. Muchas gracias.
Muchas gracias.